through rehearsal through practice
repetition through practice drilling and
rehearsing
every single day what you do is you
set up a new neural pathway in your
brain
all pain and frustration and annoyance
in our life
comes from resisting the moment before
you hit your head on the pillow
have you done something today to make
yourself proud
want to be happy build a life not just a
business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level of
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn the
best ways to build a new
habit enjoy
okay let's kick it up with way number
one scale it down with james clear
if you're looking to build a habit and
like implement it i think
the place i would recommend starting is
what i call the two-minute rule
and the two-minute rule just says take
whatever habit you're trying to build
and scale it down to something takes two
minutes or less to do so
if it's reading for example then you
know instead of read 30 books a year
that becomes read one page or do yoga
four days a week becomes take out my
yoga mat and
sometimes i explain that and people
resist a little bit they're kind of like
okay
you know like i know the real goal isn't
just to take my yoga mat out each time i
know i actually want to do the workout
so if this is some kind of
mental trick then like why would i fall
for it basically
um but i got this this guy's name's
mitch
a reader and i mentioned atomic habits
he he ended up losing over 100 pounds
and for the first six weeks that he went
to the gym he had this rule for himself
where he wasn't allowed to stay for
longer than five minutes
so you get in the car drive the gym get
out do half an exercise
get back in the car drive home and it
sounds ridiculous you know it sounds
silly you're like this is not going to
get the guy the results that he wants
but if you step back what you realize is
he was mastering the art of showing up
and he was becoming the type of person
that went to the gym
four days a week even if it was only for
two minutes um
and so the uh the point
is that and this i think is a much
deeper truth about habits
a habit must be established before it
can be improved
right it has to become the standard in
your life before you can worry about
optimizing and scaling it up
and for some reason people get so
we get so locked into like finding the
best workout program the ideal diet plan
the perfect business idea
right we're so focused on optimizing
that we don't give ourselves permission
to show up even if it's just in a small
way
and so the two-minute rule sort of helps
you overcome that you know it helps you
overcome that tendency to bite off more
than you can chew
and master the art of showing up way
number two be consistent with david
meltzer the first thing is to understand
the conscious is reliant
upon our cellular memory and the
cellular memory is really stupid it's a
short-term memory
so it needs repetition so if you think
you know running a marathon on saturdays
is going to affect your life if that's
all you do
you're much better running two miles a
day than running a marathon on saturday
i promise you
because of the way the cellular memory
works it's taking the input every day
and it needs to be reminded the next day
and the next day
in order for it to communicate with your
subconscious so
10 000 new data inputs or thoughts a day
they're determined
upon their stupid senses your eyes your
ears your nose your mouth and your touch
they are not accurate and then it relies
on your memory that's not accurate
so through the repetition you start
getting stable data that stable data
goes to the subconscious
which now has about 40 000 of these
intermediary thoughts
and the more you access them the more
impact it has
on two things one the neural pathways
that are formed
so those are habits or disciplines or
efficiencies i like to call it habits
and disciplines efficiencies
and then that's also determined on what
you call on a memory the unconscious
competency
and why i say it's important is you have
to look at these four generations back
to your great grandparents grandparents
and parents because some people
that don't understand this consistent
behavior would say
oh you know i smoke how come i can't
quit smoking
after 21 days why do i still feel like i
want it
and then other people can quit smoking
in one day it's because
genetically you're programmed right
that's why alcoholics
have alcoholic children's more uh
percentage-wise than not
so if you know your genetics you know
that it's going to take you longer or
less time
more focus or less focus in order to
effectuate the continuum
why the continuum so important though is
if you keep accessing the right
subconscious thoughts
you actually can change your dna there's
an epigenetic layer of the dna that
activates
these quantum memories that you have
these really really long-term memories
now scientists can show that it's four
generations i believe it's like
lifetimes right right right yeah yeah i
really believe that so
for me i look at my personality traits
and how they change
my characteristics how they change my
obsessions and addictions how they
change
and that creates a frequency and that
frequency is your vibration that's what
makes people different way number three
rehearse with john ashraf
many years ago when i was on the ellen
degeneres show
i was in the green room with minnie
driver and minnie driver is a hollywood
celebrity who
everybody knows around the world if you
watch a little bit of television
and i asked minnie a question i asked
her
how is it that you can take a script
that your agent gives you and how do you
become
the role so that you can either win an
academy award or an
oscar or any of the awards that they
give actors and actresses
and she said to me she said john
nobody's really ever asked me that
question
and so let me share with you what she
told me that i think will help you
understand what it's going to take for
you to not just set
goals but for you to achieve your goals
she said to me that once she gets the
script
she reads it three four five times to
see if it's really what she wants to
trade her life for
then she says when she accepts the
script and the contract that her
agent obviously connects her with the
studios with
she then goes by a process
of practice drill and rehearse and what
does that mean
well what it means is she takes hours
every single day
to practice her role in the script she
does
research on the role and then once she
thinks then feels that she has the role
really well felt in her emotional self
she then moves that to the camera now
why does that process work well the
reason the process
works is because when we have a goal
that we look at
once or twice or three times our brains
really forget what the goals are
unless we get it to go from the
conscious aware part of our personality
and our psyche
and into the unconscious implicit part
of our brain and psyche
through rehearsal through practiced
repetition
through practice drilling and rehearsing
every single day what you do is you
set up a new neural pathway in your
brain
a new pattern for your brain to not only
emotionalize
but a new pattern for your brain to have
you think about a new pattern for your
brain
to have you look for a new pattern for
your brain to get your physical body to
move
into action towards and so if you
want to achieve your goals and dreams
write out your script
and then every single day what i want
you to do
is read the script visualize and see
yourself
already being in the role
having achieved what you want to achieve
instead of just having
the goal written on a piece of paper
what i want you to also do is i want you
to
practice being that role if your
role is about being healthier then i
want you to
visualize it i want you to read it i
want you to look
at whatever you've written or whatever
you have cut out
in a magazine or from any other source
to be able to create a collage
of that goal or that dream that you have
for yourself
and then every day i want you to take
action towards that and practice that
role
until you and the goal and the dream
become one
you have to go from the i want part
to the i am part and the more you can
bridge the gap between what you want and
who you are
the more you'll be able to create an
academy award-winning performance
in your own life the more you integrate
your
vision with your emotions with your
actions
the more you will become the role the
more you will become
the person who sets goals and achieves
goals
hey this is dave meltzer and i'm going
to read my favorite paragraph
of my friend evan carmichael's book
build to serve
here's the secret dream big act small
it is important to dream big your big
dreams will motivate you
it'll inspire you to keep going when
things get tough
it'll be a rallying call for your
partners suppliers
customers and future employees
keep a hold of your huge dream
and then act small
find the smallest possible way to get
started
to take the first step to get some
momentum going
dream big but act small way number four
find your will with jocko willink i
don't really
like those words self-help or
self-management or self-improvement
i don't really like what those words
have come to mean these days
because there's a lot of people out
there that are constantly trying to
improve themselves
by looking for the one change
the one change right the one change in
their life that's gonna
make their dreams come true
and even worse on top of that there's a
lot of people out there a lot of
self-help gurus and these hyperactive
motivational speakers and these other
self-appointed
modern zen yoga warriors that they're
trying to sell
the one thing they're trying to sell the
nine
steps or the enlightened path that's
going to allow you to unlock all of your
human potential
and fulfill the dreams so you can live
the life that you've
you've always wanted to live
now i'm no guru
and i definitely don't claim to be i'm
just a man
but i will tell you this it isn't one
thing
and it isn't ten things and it isn't a
hundred things
it isn't a quick path and there are no
shortcuts
meditation won't get you there and
neither will
a miracle drug or an organic supplement
or some
superfood
getting better isn't a hack or a trick
or a one change that you need to make
getting better is a campaign it's a
campaign
it's a daily a weekly it's an hourly
fight an incessant fight that doesn't
stop against weakness and against
temptation and against laziness
it's a campaign of discipline the
campaign of hard work
and dedication it's waking up early and
going to bed late and
grinding out every second in between
every single day
so you want to get better
you want to self improve stop looking
for a shortcut
and go find your alarm clock and find
your discipline
and find your guts and your passion and
your drive and find
your will
and then and
then you will find
your freedom way number five engage in
the moment with marie forleo
here's the reality check that hit me
like a ton of bricks
all of the joy and excitement and fun
that we want in life
never comes from external circumstances
it
always comes from the energy and the
attention
and the consciousness that we bring into
each and every moment
so lori i talked about this a lot and if
you really want to solve this problem i
need you to go read
page 10 in my book make every man want
you it's all about making
isness your business so what does that
mean
making isness your business means that
you show up
in each moment and you do this moment
like you friggin mean it that means you
bring your
a game that means you bring your full
enthusiasm your attention your love
to whatever you're doing wherever you
are and whoever you're with
why because all pain and frustration
and annoyance in our life comes from
resisting the moment it comes from
saying
this moment isn't how it should be but
guess what
the moment already is so you only have
two choices in life you can either
resist it and be freaking
miserable or you can engage with the
moment
and have a damn good time in fact make
it an engagement party
you guys i'm engaged
[Applause]
with the moment
okay that's right you gotta love the
moment put a ring on it
because the truth is you can feel fully
alive in any situation
or you can feel like total crap in any
situation
it's not the circumstances it's actually
what you bring to them
once i really got this i was so much
happier i was performing in my jobs
better and ironically
everything that i wanted to create in my
future started happening
a lot faster and way number six the last
one before a very special bonus clip
is be definite with bob proctor what are
the key attributes
of prosperous people well
you know that's something i studied for
a long time i
i was not prosperous when i first picked
up this book
and it's thinking grow rich and i
started to study and that got me
studying all kinds of books
and one thing led to another that was
one of the keys i was looking for
what to what do prosperous people do
what
how do they approach things and i
believe they have
certain attributes and certain attitudes
that they form and the first one i
believe
is they have a definite and measurable
financial goal
they have a definite and measurable
financial goal they know exactly what
they're working toward
now prior to studying this i never had
any financial goals i used to hope i
would earn some more money
i always wanted more money but i never
really
never really accomplished it and i think
that was for a very good reason
and and that was because i never really
studied i never
changed i i was trying to change my
results without changing myself
so i've got six different points here
that i think
are really the key and the first one
is one i've just mentioned you've got to
have
a definite measurable financial goal
if you want to be prosperous now
prosperity doesn't just come in money it
comes in
all kinds of areas but you've got to
measure it you've got to have a target
you've got to know where you're going
the second one is that they
have all these people have definite
planned
study programs they don't just study
periodically
they have definite program for study
it's like they have definite time to eat
and they'll have a definite time to
sleep but they have a definite time to
study
and i found without exception every one
of them
had a study program and so many years
ago
i started and i had a study program now
i've got
thousands of books today although in 61
this is the first book i read
i often mentioned i didn't even read
comic books um
i have a book here open on my desk with
a book holder right here
and i picked that up had it it was a
habit actually i picked up from earl
nightingale
first time i visited him i saw he had a
book holder on his desk and asked him
what it was he says a book holder
holds a book open he says i study the
same page sometimes for weeks
and i thought that's really interesting
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i wanna know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and what is your plan of action for the
next week the sign says that when you
just watch a video you get motivated you
get inspired
you have a 35 chance of actually doing
something the following through
that believe nation is not enough 35
percent
is not enough we got to do something but
when you get inspired by watching a
video like this
and then you create a plan of action
your chances of following
will jump to 91 and when you commit
publicly
like putting your comment down below
with your plan it jumps to 95
that's what i want for you i want you to
take action your dreams are too
important
your life matters your mission has to
happen
so question of the day your biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
and i'm going to celebrate alongside
with you the pillow test
is when you put your head on the pillow
at night have you made yourself proud
today
and this is what i encourage people to
do people i work with
you're gonna hit your head on the pillow
tonight right you're you're not in bed
yet
this is a morning video series by the
way so hopefully you're not in bed yet
before your head on the pillow have you
done something today to make yourself
proud
a one-off moment isn't enough it's the
daily
it's the continuous it's the ongoing
showing yourself that you do things that
make you proud so have you done
something today
yet that makes you proud if not get up
and do something it doesn't have to take
eight hours to do it
you can make yourself proud in a second
if you wanted to just by taking on
something that's difficult
go try doing as many jumping jacks in a
row as possible
[Music]
super fast super hard go all out go try
doing as many push-ups as you can
right maybe you're going to do four
push-ups how long is that going to take
you not a lot of time
doesn't have to take a lot of time to
make yourself proud
but working that muscle to make yourself
proud
every single day has this compound
effect
to then bleed over into every area of
your life to actually take on the big
projects that will move your business
and your life forward
so pass the pillow test today it has to
happen
i want to address my comments to those
of you that have learned the five second
rule
you've tried the countdown 54321 and
it's not working i gotta level with you
the five-second rule always works it's
backed by science and it has helped
change the lives of
millions of people the problem is not
the rule
the problem is you actually don't want
to change
i'm dead serious i want i want you to
just stop and think about that for a
minute
for people who try to count down but
then don't actually push themselves
forward
for those of you that that are
struggling with self-doubt struggling to
get up on time struggling to make the
calls to grow your business struggling
to stay motivated you know about the
five-second rule but you don't
use it there's a simple reason why
you're not using it you don't want to
change
look change is hard i get it if you're
going to change anything about your life
you're going to have to face the unknown
you're going to have to step out of your
comfort zone you're going to have to try
something new you're going to have to
risk rejection and judgment
it's scary i get it that's why most
people never
change so if you're like leanne
and you've got all the tools at your
disposal but you still
are stuck the reason why you're stuck is
you don't
want to change yet so stop complaining
about the tools
and go inward and actually examine what
are you afraid of
seriously what do you get out of staying
stuck what do you
get from staying heavy what do you get
from not making the money that you want
what do you get from dating a string of
losers
you get safety i don't know you get the
ability to complain
are you the one that's constantly
dominating all your friendships because
you're constantly griping about how bad
your life is i don't know what you're
getting out of it but you're getting
something
the moment you decide that you're sick
and tired of it the moment that you
decide that you are
so ready to change the five second rule
this puppy right here the five four
three two one it'll be there
and it'll work and look when you start
deciding that it's time to change you
may have to use five four three two one
five thousand times a day
for weeks on end because you're pushing
through self-doubt and you're pushing
through procrastination and you're
pushing through resignation and you're
pushing through fear over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
again
and then what's going to happen and i
see this happening around the world
i know that it works we have proof that
it works
if you use 54321 and you push through
everything that's stopping you right now
because you
this is your year this is the moment
that you're going to change
at some point something's going to click
and the momentum is going to kick in
and suddenly change isn't going to be
scary
change is going to be what's happening i
think if a modeling genius and genius
leaves clues
i'm thinking about okay where are they
and when are they doing these things so
certain people are early birds some
people are night owls
so i could teach people like i teach
people how to read one book a week
i really think leaders are readers that
in order to stay competitive in today's
day and age
if somebody has decades of experience
and they put it into a book and you can
sit down and read that in a few days
download decades in the days i mean i'm
preaching to a choir for everyone's
watching
but that that's that's a superpower
right that's a huge advantage
and so i'm thinking about but some
people when i'm telling them the
practice and i get these real results in
30 and you know about four or five weeks
where it's permanent where they can read
300 faster with the same or better
comprehension essentially
something in 20 minutes it takes
normally takes normal people an hour but
the reason why but you have to practice
but some people will practice at
inopportune times of the day and they
won't get the same results
so part of it is self-awareness knowing
you're what they call your chronotype
when's the optimal time to do this like
for depending on your body type there's
certain times of the day it's better to
work out there's better times a day to
be able to make love the better times of
the day to be able to read to check
email to ask for a raise
so i would think about like if geniuses
found to find their element their sweet
spot
and they set up their routines and their
rituals throughout the day to be able to
align with the time when they're most
productive
right if they're not if they don't have
a lot of energy in the morning working
out is probably not as good as
doing some other time so the when and
the where and setting up your
environment for success because all your
triggers are there
that allow them so i think geniuses set
themselves up so for example
they have their laptop but they only use
their laptop for work and it's anchored
that's part of their environment it's
anchored to get them into flow states to
be able to write or be productive
they don't use their laptop to watch
binge on netflix
right they have a very they have an ipad
that they use when they do that because
that's the
state that they want to anchor for that
and they don't use that ipad to do work
you know setting up your environment
like your bedroom like we just did a
whole episode on sleep hacks and how to
optimize your sleep because that's a big
you know personal challenge for me for
many years because i had suffered from
sleep apnea it's a breathing disorder i
stopped breathing 200 times at night for
at least 10 seconds
which is the equivalent of somebody
coming in and just choking and
suffocating you 200 times a night
and so i would actually the reason why
i'm so adamant about productivity and
learning hacks is because
for the longest time for literally five
years straight and you know this
i've slept about 90 minutes to two hours
a night total
and you know how you feel when you get
like one bad night's sleep and how like
where your focus is your energy level
and your how do i get these horrible
migraines
and it's forced me to double down in my
practices
you know in terms of like i have a
limited amount of time i have to focus
on the things that really matter
resources and stuff but anyway going
back to like my bedroom is sacred space
right it's i don't do work in there i
keep it because that's my trigger to be
able to rest go into parasympathetic
space i set up my environment so i have
my blackout curtains on my crowning pads
so it's optimized my restful sleep that
i do get
so environment so genius leaves clues
they set up genius environments for
themselves
i've been a note card taker carrier
for as long as i can remember though
this leather
one which i got from the company i think
they're called levenger they make like
bags and stuff
i've had this one for about 10 years so
i use
three by five cue cards and they
all have different colors to do
different things now
um my daily list is the first card
so these are the things that i want
to do today and truthfully i don't
always get everything done on my today
card
probably two-thirds of the time i do
go to bed with everything on the daily
card done
but if not you will flip it over
and then the next day take something
there if it's still relevant and put it
on that card along with the next things
that need to be done
i then have and by the way i sometimes
use a white card or a green
it's either white or green is always my
daily card um
my uh pink card is my number two card
and you can see that
this was last week so i'm like a car i'm
cheap with these things so it's like i
i just love the fact that i'm saving
money by using both sides of it
so for this week's pink card um
i have all of the things that have to be
done by
sunday so every week i redo the pink
card
and as you can see for all of my things
there's like a little square box
and it says next to the thing so a lot
of the times
it'll be a box with a half
check through it which is when i'm
partially done with that task so the
task is fully done when you have the
two checks through the box so i have
boxes here that have
nothing i haven't done them yet i have
others that have a single
hash through which means it's in
progress and i have others that are
fully
hashed through which means they're
they're all the way done
um i then have my orange card which is
um it's a very it's a notice this one to
get this color of orange it has to come
on this awful
chartreuse stripey color on the back
which i don't reuse
this is very patient specific so i don't
have a big spanish
so i have a very a very patient specific
group of things that go on here
the white card which is different from
the white card that i lead with because
it sits far enough back in the pack it
never gets confused
has all of my long-term sort of
just random personal things that i don't
want to cloud on my weekly list
although intermittently things from here
will go on the weekly list
so again i don't want to read these
things because they won't make any sense
to you but it's
it's just a bunch of stuff like oh you
got to fix the autoresponder in your
email and
oh i got to return my range finder
because it's not working very well
and oh i need to sync the way this thing
works with that thing
it might take me two months to get
through this list
and that's fine because you know
intermittently things from this list
will make it onto the weekly pink list
and obviously things from the weekly
pink list intermittently make it onto
the green list
[Music]
unrelated my last card is just a place
where i keep track of
stupid things that i like to do so i
don't even know why i carry this i think
tim ferriss once
asked me to make a list of all the dumb
things i do
and i started carrying this list around
which has like egg boxing
tearing phone books counting forks and
knives doing my tsa
voice playing the what if game and
pretending to be in a little bit of a
rush and every time i think of another
dumb thing i like to do
it goes on that list so that is the card
carrying system obviously highly
modifiable
you can do anything you want that's the
beauty of the card system
yeah i think i've used it before too as
well i have a purple card it's called my
people to kill list hmm
people don't have enough rules in their
life for themselves so for instance i
get out of bed in 10 minutes or less
doesn't matter and i don't want to
that's why i have the rule because i
went your mind
literally i went through a period where
i would lay in bed for three to four
hours awash in shame and my inability to
get out of bed
and it just embarrassed me and so i felt
badly about myself so i wanted to make a
change so i knew that i needed a bright
line
so bright line 10 minutes or less you
get out of bed as soon as you realize
you're awake that's it
so and the rule is more specific it's
like i have to have had at least five
hours of sleep
um but once you put the rule in place
then you just live by it and that's how
you earn credibility like right now i
don't feel the way telling you that that
i want to feel
this is a good moment he's on my team
i'm pointing at him this is a good
moment so i'm saying this and i don't
feel good about saying it why because
today
i don't know what happened i got out of
bed in 11 minutes
and i was so literally time it oh yeah i
mean from waking up to actually
physically getting out of the bed
correct my feet must be on the floor and
i
must be standing up before it ticks over
into the 11th minute
and today i don't know what happened i i
was i was aware of the time i knew i
needed to get up
and for whatever reason one of the
minutes just went faster than i thought
when i looked back i was like damn it
and so i'm surprised you even made it
here today then right
so now this comes into like knowing how
to handle something like that like if
you totally fall apart because you don't
live up 20 rules you're violating
another one of my rules
which is don't do anything that doesn't
move you towards your goals so it's like
yes i it is a part of my identity
to confess this so because i'm talking
about it i want to say it now to an
audience
it's the only thing that will allow me
to reset and be able to feel good about
it again
because i don't lie when i miss it i own
it well look if your biggest problem is
it took you 11 minutes to get out sadly
that's not my biggest
this is a high quality program right yes
very true but my thing is people don't
have the rules
and so i have other rules for instance i
wear a size 32 pant
that's just that's it and so no matter
what your waist is
no no i won't let my waist get out of
line with that
so i use the pants as a way to guide now
i would go down if i got so lean that i
was you know 31 that's not a problem
but i'm not going to allow myself to go
up and it's super tempting like
especially around christmas
i don't try to hold abs through the
winter so during christmas like right
now i do not have abs
so and i'm totally fine with that i
switch a different part of my mentality
i during the holidays my wife and i
definitely celebrate with food and it's
amazing and i love it the most
so but if that celebration took me up to
like 32s don't fit anymore
i gotta come back because i have a rule
so it's like that's how i
keep myself in a lane i keep myself from
getting into trouble i know the things
that i accept for myself
what i don't accept for myself and it's
all like stated it's very clear
i'm responsible ed to move
on what i see today
there's a whole bunch of people they're
wanting to hold and not move
because they don't see three days five
days you know two years out whatever
and what i'm saying is it's kind of like
the lights of a
of a car if i go to the parking lot at
night turn on the lights and
say oh my gosh i can't go where i don't
see my house right
well no no no get the car start moving
in the direction supposed to move it
and guess what you only get about 300
feet of light
you don't get to see your house you've
got to utilize the light you've got
so that you can get to where you want to
go and so many people
are uncomfortable with that with that
light yeah because it's there's
well it's not long enough and what's
around the corner and and the whole
issue is you don't you know what
you don't know what's around the corner
until you go around the corner oh gosh
that's so good and so you just
so you have to be very comfortable which
i
am you have to be very comfortable with
traveling not having all the answers
so true but can i tell you something the
only way you get all the answers
is to go all the way through absolutely
you don't get all the answers on this
side
and so if i've got to have it lined up
and straight and right and i feel
comfortable with it
then i'll never be the leader and i i
here i really believe this head i
believe a lot of leaders fall short
because they're unwilling to take what
they know now and
act on it and so therefore they never
get to know what they could know i think
i had a lot of beat up
i mean emotional mental psychological
beat up i was like
beating myself to death psychologically
for
decades of my life those are and that
one thing brother because i know you've
written so eloquently about this for
everybody
that started with you acknowledging and
realizing a pattern
yeah so we have these patterns of
behavior right and so
when you acknowledge a pattern you have
that does not serve you
it loses a lot of its power over you
just by you
seeing it being aware of it like for
example in business for me
usually when i'm doing well there's this
really intense version of me
i don't always like that guy but man
does he produce a lot of results he gets
insane he gets paid he gets rid of his
pain
and and i'm back sort of in the hunt in
a lot of my business in such a way and
that guy's sort of re-emerging
and i've asked my and there's this part
of all of us that think
this that's why i'm successful so
if i took this intensity away or i took
this self-doubt away
or i took this anxiety away i'll lose my
mechanism to achieve we all think this
it's complete bs
or not to interrupt you but yeah or if i
take this away i'll lose the opportunity
for girls to want me or have sex with
women or to lose the weight or to do
this if i take this away
right we think that's part of our secret
recipe when in fact
brother and you've realized this too
you're in a more blissful relationship
now
that you were succeeding in spite of
those patterns not because of them
what they are is they become part of
your identity so you think that's why
they produce these results but you're
winning instead of them in spite of them
and so for me just when they rear their
head i'm like i'm doing that stupid
pattern again here i go again
and it loses some of its power over me
and so you're
do you're a million percent right and
that's why i
i feel so such optimism about my life
is because i know i kind of know me
so i know when i'm doing that guy here
he goes the worry in me
here he goes the overreacting me you're
doing it again
and it's almost like a clown show when i
do it instead of me going well that's
why i win i mean hey
you may not like that guy but man then
he became a millionaire look at my view
look at my house look at this yeah
and then you use these external things
to validate your own negative pattern
in the morning when i meditate i set my
intention i
literally know how powerful my ego is
and that i could be easily triggered to
react
like a silverback at any moment like
it's so easy for me to go to that place
if i'm not intentional about the way i
want to be throughout the day
so that's why when i'm meditating i'm
thinking about any scenario that could
happen today
with my girlfriend what if she gets
upset at me for something that i forgot
to do how am i going to respond
uh you know if a team meeting doesn't go
well how am i going to respond
if someone misses a deadline if someone
does this if someone i just try to go
through things how can i respond
if anything happens i'm going to react
to everyone around me i'm going to take
ownership
so i try to get clear on my intention
for the day and
in any area of my life and when i do
that i feel like i'm prepared
i think most people humans in general
aren't as prepared for these challenges
and then therefore they repeat
they go back into just wearing a mask
when any situation occurs where they
feel attacked
let's put on the mask because that's
what feels natural
when you're feeling gratitude and your
heart is open you're broadcasting
energy into the field now frequency
frequency you lay the intent of the
thought of
your health or your wealth that
frequency can
carry the thought of your wealth it can
carry the thought of your health
if you're suffering you can't the
suffering does not
carry that energy does not carry the
thought of your wealth it carries a
different set of thoughts
so then so then we're teaching people
how to self-regulate because if you're
going to believe in that future
that you're imagining with all of your
heart it better be open and activated
and you better know how to self-regulate
and you have to know
the moment you disconnect from the
energy of your future because of some
circumstance in your life
and you lose that feeling if you're
practicing it on a daily basis with your
eyes closed
then the next level is to be able to
open your eyes and do it
right in the moment and be able to
self-regulate and change
the the frustration from some experience
in your life
back to the energy of your future now
that requires great awareness and great
effort but if you have a community of
people
that are practicing this on a daily
basis and they're connected to their
future because that's where their
their mind is they begin to
want the future more
than the emotions of the past so we've
done enough measurements now lewis
to know that we can teach people how to
do that and we have evidence that people
can sustain it
for 45 minutes to an hour it's a skill
now they know that they know how to do
it so now they have
brain coherence and heart coherence well
once the heart begins to become orderly
and coherent
it acts as an amplifier and it drives
energy to the brain so now
the brain is getting more energy once
the heart is open and then you're
thinking different set of thoughts
and those thoughts produce different
chemicals for you to feel more of that
and here comes uh
nitric oxide from oxytocin and then all
of a sudden your heart literally starts
to swell
it literally begins to open up and
there's more energy going there and now
you're coming from a different level of
mind
the goal or the outcome that you are
aiming for
must be something that fills you with
positive emotion
in other words emotion is a force
multiplier
so the problem many people have is that
their goal is
our goals or visions or ideas that come
from
the outside world it's not coming from
within them
it's coming from what media or
television or your parents or your
your family tells you you need to do you
need to be driving that sports car
you need that beautiful apartment with a
pool you need this you need that
but true goals true intention comes from
within
and when it comes from within you tend
to have more emotion towards it
because you're not blindly following
someone else's path
my son learning how to skateboard you
you were talking about dropping in oh
gosh me sure that yeah that don't remind
me that's a very painful part of my uh
part of my past no it's true my this was
i don't know maybe five years ago six
years ago because my son
he's pretty passionate about it i mean
passionate enough that we
built a huge half pipe in the in the
backyard
and of course you want to do things with
your kids um
and so i wanted to learn how to
skateboard and then one of those
fundamental things you learn in
skateboarding is that
there's that act called dropping in
where you're standing on the edge of the
half pipe and you've got to drop forward
and
roll down that slope but it's something
that if you hesitate
if you lean back if you hedge your bets
you are
guaranteed to end up in your ass um and
the only
only way to do it is to fully commit to
lean forward to put all your weight in
that front foot and down you go
but what did your son tell you about
leaning too far forward
oh i think he said that no one ever
leans too far forward
that it's impossible to lean too far
forward that whatever your mind is
saying this is too far forward you're
still
probably too far backwards in other
words
don't worry about it go for it commit
you
are integral to making change like
you're powerful
if you focus in on your environment if
you connect to becoming the best in that
space
you are an incredible asset to yourself
to a team
to other people to anyone because all of
these are needed
but the worst thing is when we try to do
someone else's duty and there's
this great verse in the bhagavad-gita
which i read as a monk which says that
it's better to do your own nature even
if only 50
than doing another ones perfectly when
we aim to do someone else's work even
perfectly
we'll always be challenged we'll always
be let down that's why we feel stressed
that's why we feel pressure in life
when you're doing pressure in your own
environment you feel the pressure
but you get through it you dive through
it kelly mcgonagall talks about that in
a book called the upside of stress
that when you're working in your passion
stress doesn't feel like stress anymore
you still experience it it just doesn't
feel like it but when you're not working
in your passion
stress feels like stress pressure feels
like pressure it gets really really
heavy
and we all experience that in our lives
and if you're experiencing that in your
career
you're experiencing that in your life
find areas of your day where you can be
pursuing your passion think of
what we do in life as mapping out new
terrain
right so think of the think of our life
as like the earth and we're explorers
right and some people take one path
they go to work every day they do the
same thing same couple of friends they
do
and that's and they're okay with this
one straight line path they don't see
any of the world
they just they do this they go do their
thing and they come back that's one
version
and there's some people who say this
this path that everybody says is great
this path that everybody like says this
is the security this is the safety this
is
how life is supposed to be it's like
screw that and they wander off the path
right if you're here with us today
you're here with me today you're part of
the inner circle
um that means that you're someone who's
wandered off the path congratulations
the path sucks
the path is what everybody else does the
path that and if you're if somebody's on
it and they're miserable they want you
to be on the path with them when they
see you straight like no no get back on
here it's not safe out there
no it's not safe on the path we have one
life we got to squeeze
every bit of juice out of this life you
don't want to look back at the end of
your life being 100 years old be in the
hospital go
wow i walk the same path every day i'm
so glad i played it safe no screw that
no one says that then you're like why
didn't i step off the path why didn't i
go for more why didn't i tap into my why
didn't i go after being an artist go
after
real estate investing go after doing my
own online business go out to the
fitness world go in the coaching world
go sing why why didn't i do it because
someone told you staying on the path was
smart screw that get off the path
but if you think about that and you're
mapping out terrain so
just think if we're explorers if we're
on the path
we get to explore new territory i'm
going to read some of these guys
we get to explore new territory but when
you
explore new territory you've kind of
mapped out that terrain now if you go
off the path and you find a cliff
you can mark that if you find paradise
you could mark that
if you find water you mark that you find
mountains you mark that you find the
ocean you mark it
and all of a sudden you start exploring
for me
going through this process i mapped out
a whole new bunch of terrain
i'm not that old i'm not listen can i
tell you something
i feel absolutely positively
bulletproof because i face the biggest
fear of my life there's nothing that can
get me let me just tell you something i
drive down the road and somebody cuts me
off i wave to them
i order chicken for dinner they bring me
steak well done i eat the steak well
done and say thank you
because the little doesn't matter
anymore if you if you want another level
of life get bigger problems and solve
bigger problems
literally solve bigger problems and
watch your life go to another level
watch the little [ __ ] fall away the
stuff that used to bug you'd be like why
did i let that bug me
get a deeper set of problems and solve
that and when you're done with that
solve the next one and when you're done
with that solve the next one instead of
solving hundred dollar problems you know
what my wish for you is
solve million dollar problems they're
the same amount of stress
if you need a hundred bucks to pay the
bill or you need a million i assure you
it's the same stress
so why not add more zeros talk to people
about
taking care of themselves like there's
someone who they have responsibility for
and that's not a political issue too
it's it's uh
it's an injunction to assuming that you
have a certain intrinsic value
you know and that it's necessary for
that value to manifest itself
for you to push yourself against the
world to challenge yourself because
otherwise
what you're capable of won't manifest
itself it it has to be
developed it has to be called forth by
necessity right you have to pick a hard
problem and try to solve it and push
yourself against it
in order for and you have to try to do
that truthfully and responsibly
in order for what it is that you're
intrinsically
capable of and composed of to come to
the forefront
and that seems like a very positive
thing as far as i'm concerned to
encourage people to be responsible for
themselves and for other people and also
to point out that
that you have a moral responsibility to
do so
for yourself just as you do for others
and
i i think that that message has been
very
helpful to people at least that's what
they've told me
the i and it's predicated that the rule
is predicated on
the old judeo-christian idea the oldest
idea in some sense that
you know that there's a relationship
between
logos which is truthful speech and
communication and
bringing things into being from chaotic
potential that's
the idea that's put forward in genesis
and also the idea that men
and women alike are made in the image of
god which suggests that
like god we have the capability of
affecting potential affecting the
possible future and turning it into the
actual present and that we do that
at least in part as a consequence of our
ethical choices
motivation is an emotion you learn to
cultivate
by using your mind your body your
greater consciousness
to ensure that you feel that pull of
purpose
that you feel that energy inside that
says i
want to create i want to contribute i
want to be my best self i want to
connect with people
and so motivation is something we're
going to have to generate
on a consistent basis i know many of you
are at hpa and you hear
me say you know all the time you have to
learn to bring the joy because the power
plant doesn't have energy
it generates energy motivation is
something me
the motivation guy i have the best
selling book
of the entire century with motivation
the title it's called the motivation
manifesto if you haven't read it
and the motivation manifesto is like
if anything is is is imbued in that book
it is like this ferocity and this
fierceness and this attention
to living our best lives but it has to
be like generated because even though
i'm the
motivation guy there's plenty of days i
wake up and i'm like
i don't feel like it there's plenty of
days
there's plenty of moments where just
like you i'm just like i'd rather be
lazy and do
nothing right now and that's okay that's
that's part of homeostasis that's part
of our
our human body to want to power down to
relax to chill out
but too much of that can lead to an
unfulfilling life
so we must learn to generate
the emotions of drive desire
go get in this whatever you want to call
motivation
what is it that prevents people from
doing the things they already want to do
in life
the most basic answer i'm sorry it's so
simple but it's true it's fear
you know people making this complex
process this almost told me that i don't
understand why i don't do this why i
feel this way
it's called fear everybody's afraid
we're not enough everybody's afraid
we're not rich enough smart enough young
enough
quick enough fast enough it's human
nature but the secret is to do it anyway
i know that sounds so simplistic
my work when i'm working with somebody
is showing how to condition themselves
like building a muscle
so that you take action first
automatically because if you don't do
that it's hard you lose momentum it's
like how do i get started where do i go
and i tell people throw a rock wherever
it drops start there the next person
walks by go you're the first person
after the rock do anything
to start the process of moving forward
rather than like fear stop you
and your goal the whole time is like
millions i got to become a millionaire
oh yeah
yeah from from david mansion palm trees
and those convertible cars
wow would you say your home now is very
similar to what you drew
very much i have 11 palm trees in the
house
king palm trees is double lot huge curb
appeal
and when you park those cars in front
it's just like that picture i love that
yeah
let me ask you this were you writing
down affirmations i mean were you
writing visualizing yourself are you
writing down the goals i mean
what did you do to ingrain it or was it
just a mental thing it was all mental
i mean although you know the past 10
years i've been running my goals every
day
you know daily weekly monthly yearly
my goals i actually have a spreadsheet i
made 25 years ago
of how how much i'm going to be worth by
tom 67 i
put all these numbers in there you know
if i make 10
a year with this one house i have i sell
it
i buy two houses and i use this formula
and it's
really interesting it's called the
aftermath and then there's another one
it's called actual aftermath and i've
been
i haven't done it for a few years but
for every year
on january i used to compare my actual
aftermath but the aftermath i did many
years ago to see if i'm on the right
track
wow yeah that's incredible so you know
you have to keep your mind
uh to stand the right path you have to
constantly write your goals
you have to have some kind of uh you
know
exactly what is batching to explain it
in simplest terms
we can talk about laundry all right so
you wouldn't do
your laundry every time you have a new
pair of dirty socks you wait
for a certain critical mass of dirty
laundry to accumulate
and then you do the laundry why
same with post office if you have many
different types of mail that are going
to come together you need to mail you're
going to wait for a certain critical
mass as opposed to just going there for
every single letter
because there's a setup cost there is a
task
switching cost getting in the car
driving there spending the gas spending
the time
laundry putting it all together
detergent and so on
right so the the time and labor involved
in doing one letter
or 20 or one pair of socks or entire
basket of clothing
is the same and you want to be both
effective and efficient
with your allocation of resources ie
time
if you apply those to business you can
apply them in a million and one
different ways
and i'll give you a few examples one of
the most common
i suppose directional questions or
specifics
that i'm asked about is frequency well
do i batch on a daily basis do i batch
on a weekly basis do i batch on a
monthly or quarterly basis
and the answer is i do all of those
things but you don't have to try it all
at once and i would not encourage you
do that i would encourage you to perhaps
try one or two approaches and see what
works for you this is a very
personal set of techniques you develop a
portfolio that works for yourself
let me tell you a few things that i and
others do for instance
you might decide that on a given day
from the time you wake up until lunch is
your primary
creation period this could be writing it
could be recording
it could be anything that is proactively
creative and synthesis then once you
have lunch
you are permitted to do administrative
tasks
phone calls email triage calendaring and
so on
i do this quite a lot particularly from
tuesday to thursday on certain weeks
on a weekly basis i know the ceo of a
very well-known startup
pretty much everyone watching this would
know this company and
instead of batching on a daily basis
looking at his week monday to friday he
might have day one
administrative tasks day two hr hiring
day three product day four marketing
and on each of those days he will focus
on
thematically or categorically those
types of tasks
that is yet another approach and very
commonly i will batch phone calls
on mondays and fridays and in
i would say even broadly speaking this
is voice related
tasks so i will have phone calls
and podcast recording on mondays and
fridays
and this helps to prevent also
interruptions and task switching
that can result if you have
miscellaneous phone calls and podcasts
scattered throughout the week
makes it very difficult to do deep work
on anything that might require three to
five hours of
uninterrupted time on a on a quarterly
basis
you could look at batch producing or
completing
certain types of normally scattered
activities
for instance i am recording this video
right now
during a content generation week where
a week is blocked out once per quarter
to focus on
answering common questions that all of
you or my readers or listeners have
asked and so on and so forth
on a say six month to yearly
basis i have started in the last few
years
batching travel why would i batch travel
and there are many different reasons to
best travel
one of my reasons is that i want to
practice being
off the grid for extended periods of
time
to not only remind myself and prove to
myself that it is possible to do that
and no
the internet will not stop the universe
will not end if you are unavailable and
unreachable for certain periods of time
and also to rejuvenate to recharge being
away from social media
and keyboards and laptops screens and so
on batching
is one of the fundamental concepts that
you need to understand
if you understand the principle the
reasons for it the concepts you can
come up with your own examples to
experiment with
these are not permanent changes think of
them as two-week experiments
one tiny thing that you can test
assuming that it's on a daily
or weekly basis and try it out see what
works
keep what works reject what doesn't add
what is uniquely your own
borrowing from bruce lee with that and
before you know it you will have
a reliable dependable way of making
yourself more effective and more
efficient which is
your bespoke iteration of batching
in book five of meditations aurelius
writes at dawn when you have trouble
getting out of bed
tell yourself i have to go to work as a
human being
what do i have to complain of if i'm
going to do what i was born for the
things i was brought into the world to
do
or is this what i was created for to
huddle under the blankets and stay warm
but it's nicer here so you're born to
feel nice
instead of doing things and experiencing
them don't you see the plants the birds
the ants and spiders and bees going
about their individual tasks putting the
world in order as best they can
and you're not willing to do your job as
a human being why aren't you running to
do what your nature demands
but we have to sleep sometime agreed but
nature set a limit on that
as it did on eating and drinking and
you're over that limit you've had more
than enough of that
but not of working there you're still
below your quota you don't love yourself
enough
or you'd love your nature too and what
it demands of you people who love what
they do
wear themselves down doing it they even
forget to wash or eat
do you have less respect for your own
nature than the engraver does for
engraving the dancer for dance the miser
for money or the social climber for
status
when they're really possessed by what
they do they'd rather stop eating and
sleeping than give up practicing their
arts
he's telling you to respect your choice
of path in life enough that you consider
it to be your very nature to be instinct
just as spiders and bees and ants get up
every day and are driven by their
instincts so should you be driven by the
actions that are demanded by your goals
if yesterday you decided you wanted to
get up early so you could work on your
goals but
now you're lying in bed and you feel
comfortable and you don't want to get up
then you need to focus your mind on your
nature on the path you've chosen and let
that override
your current desire other aspects of the
art of gaining self-discipline like
exercises for building grit or systems
that commit you to things ahead of time
are important but they take a backstep
to this one key insight
for marcus aurelius respecting your work
as your very nature and tailoring your
decisions and actions in accordance with
that was the most important part of
building discipline
[Music]
if you want to know how to make any new
habit stick with john astrath check out
the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there the first thing
is to have a different expectation
than i'm going to change in a day or a
week or in 21 days
whenever i try to change anything